c'est une contre âgées qu'on organisait
aujourd'hui les activistes d'extinction
rébellions et autres ong type les amis
de la terre notre affaire à tous ils
contestent les pratiques de total alors
qu'est ce qui a changé ces derniers
temps pour la firme pétrolière certains
actionnaires plus technique veulent des
améliorations en termes de bilan
environnemental
il peut être pour les satisfaire total
aujourd'hui à changer de nom il
s'appelle désormais total énergie grâce
au vote quasi unanime des actionnaires
aujourd'hui ils veulent communiquer sur
le fait qu'il développe les énergies
renouvelables notamment le
photovoltaïque et pour les écologistes
ceci n'est qu'un écran de fumée pour
attirer les investisseurs car total
continue les destructions de
l'environnement ont d'ailleurs des
témoins ici contester leur pratique en
algérie ou en birmanie par exemple on
écoute juliette renaud des amis de la
terre nouveaux amis de la terre ça va
quand on est mené sur plusieurs de ces
projets par exemple contre les projets
de total en ouganda en tanzanie où il
prévoit de forer plus de 400 puits dont
132 dans une aire naturelle protégée et
de construire un oléoduc géant et tout
ça ça aussi conduit à la l'expropriation
de plus de 100000 personnes qui sont
rougis aujourd'hui privés de leurs
terres et donc de leurs moyens de
subsistance et on voit le même scénario
se répéter par exemple au mozambique où
les projets gaziers non seulement aussi
accaparer des terres des populations
mais nourrissent aussi de conflit armé
pareil aussi à d'autres et celle
demandant dans d'autres pays au nigeria
depuis depuis des années en birmanie ou
total soutient financièrement la junte
et donc voilà on est là pour montrer la
vérité sur les problèmes total cette
année plusieurs investisseurs avaient
choisi de ne pas voter pour le plan de
total le trouvant insuffisant mais cette
stratégie climat de totale aujourd'hui a
été votée par les actionnaires
pour le moment donc cette opposition n'a
pas fait le poids face aux décisions de
total d'explorer de nouveaux gisements
pétroliers et gaziers